they were some of the most vulnerable
people in the country forty people with
a learning disability or autism who died
while admitted to an NHS program that
was supposed to protect them we don't
know all of their names and we don't
know all of their stories but now for
the first time two families have spoken
out about a system they believe let
their loved ones down Amanda brierley
was autistic she was just 20 when she
took her own life on a mental health
unit in 2016
hours after returning from a Christmas
home visit we got a phone call early
hours of Boxing Day morning to say she'd
been taken to a Laroy Lester Royal
Infirmary and she was in a serious state
and eventually on the 28th of December
they said that you know her organs were
failing and therefore they had to decide
whether to turn the Machine off Amanda
had a history of self-harm but she
should never have been on a mental
health ward because it was unsuitable
for people with autism in this interview
recorded for the NHS Trust in leicester
share that was managing her care she
explained why and that makes me feel
Amanda had been waiting seven months to
be transferred to an appropriate
facility under an NHS program called
transforming care on our last night she
was supposed to be under one-to-one
supervision to stop her hurting herself
one of several failures in care her
inquest heard was unacceptable I think
we all knew all along that it was never
the right place for her to go but there
was nowhere else to go
and she was in crisis and needed to be
somewhere where she could be kept safe
really needs a to get resources together
to understand you know if somebody's got
a need and they need to go to a
specialist place those resources need to
be easily findable more than 2,000
people with learning disabilities and
autism are currently in institutions
waiting to get the appropriate care they
need and that the NHS has promised clive
tracy was one of them clive was the life
and soul of the party he could have gone
on forever
he had a learning disability in epilepsy
and spent most of his life in care homes
and hospitals he was not autistic but he
was in an autism unit fifty miles away
from home when he had a seizure in 2017
when my phone rung at seven o'clock in
the morning I didn't realize it was my
brother she said your brother's dead I
would never wish on anyone the cold
empty delivery of my brother's death on
anyone he never came home we brought him
home the day laid to rest this CCTV
footage screened at Clyde's inquest
shows staff trying to revive him the
inquest was told they had only basic
first-aid training and then a machine
that helped him breathe at night was
broken
the inquest ruled Clive died of natural
causes
but his family believes years of
inappropriate care and inadequate
support contributed to his death how can
a system in this day and age not support
an individual that shows it shows a lot
of clear signs Clive's disabilities were
not as severe as some individuals
unfortunately have Clark wasn't autistic
but he lost his liking in an autistic
facility when Sky News first revealed
that 40 people had died in the
transforming care program the government
promised an NHS review of every death
and the care Minister said this as its
mr. speaker there is no indication that
any of the deaths were untoward or that
due process was not followed in every
single case but we are double checking
each and every one but four months on
the review is still not complete and
labour shadow care minister says
families need answers now the treatment
of autistic people and people's learning
disabilities in these sort of units
these assessment and treatment units is
a national scandal the response we got
back in October when I raised this issue
was that well there's nothing untoward
about these deaths I think your
continued research and the examination
of these issues is showing that there is
the NHS says that all these deaths will
be reviewed and in future all fatalities
will be examined as a matter of course
but while the Department of Health says
the care of people with learning
disabilities and autism is a priority a
target to move at least half of people
out of institutions into community care
has been pushed back five years and in
many places cuts to local authority
budgets I mean that care simply doesn't
exist dear Lisa can you help me find a
new home thank you Dan shall the private
care provider that ran the facility in
which Clive died said staff was saddened
by his death and extended their
sympathies to his family but said they
could not comment on individual patients
loved Satie olestra didn't get the post
no what I and I know the family would
like to see is that justice is given
four o'clock we find the truth there we
can conclude the people can say we made
errors but we've learned from it in the
one being of the treaty case I think
Lester sheer partnership NHS trusts have
apologised to Amanda's family and say
they've made changes to systems and
staff training sad lost you know I paid
your future with a hump week yeah yeah I
protect your future and just hope that
you know nobody else has to go through
this
we are all individuals I just say never
shame
just listen that's all I doubt
Amanda's is one voice among many
families want them to be heard Paul
Kelso Sky News